all right a 5.5 inch display Snapdragon
805 and two gigs of ram 64 gigs of
storage a 3000 milliamp hour battery and
Android LC that's how easy it is to just
rent off a list of specs of things you
want to see in the next Nexus phone but
I'm actually gonna give you a couple
more specific things that I would like
to see in maybe you'll agree with me but
all of this stuff is prefaced with the
fact that I'm pretty confident that the
nexus program will continue to exist
there's been a lot of talk about
rebranding it or Android silver or
whatever it's going to be changed -
bottom line is it has to exist in some
form because Google still needs some
hardware partnership to show off the
next version of Android on what they
think the hardware should look like a
case in point on screen versus
off-screen buttons before the Nexus S or
the Galaxy Nexus every version of
Android was used on phones with off
screen buttons when they move those two
on-screen buttons slowly you've seen OMS
adopt that and that's kind of what you
expect to see in a Nexus phone it's kind
of leading the charge for the way Nexus
develops so that's why I think this
Nexus program will continue to exist and
that's why I want to talk about it so
I've actually been using a Google Play
edition HTC One m8 on or off as a sort
of a daily driver for the past couple of
weeks now but I've actually switched my
sim card back into the Nexus 5 my Nexus
5 running the Android L Developer
Preview not even a beta and not even
close to a final release
but it's that good so I really like it
and I think the switch over to this
material design stuff seems like a great
opportunity to refresh the hardware so
the first thing I'd like to see in the
next Nexus is camera movements and this
is actually not a hardware thing as a
matter of fact the Nexus 5 actually has
a pretty good camera in terms of
hardware it's an 8 megapixel sensor made
by Sony it's used in a couple of other
high-end smartphones but other phones
using the same sensor take better
pictures in the Nexus 5 and that's
because stock Android has always been
really poor in the image processing
department for whatever reason this has
never been a big focus for Google and as
far as effort they put into the camera
it's usually way more into the user
interface for the camera app to actually
take pictures so they've been lacking in
the image processing department so I'd
love to see
a focus here in the next version of
Android and the next hardware now second
up is battery improvements now I've
actually started to see the beginning of
this in the Android L Developer Preview
believe it or not my Nexus 5 lasts a lot
longer on battery than it ever did with
KitKat running this developer preview
and it's not even the final version of
the OS so for this next phone I'd love
to see a solid battery increase in there
maybe 2800 milliamp hours or 3000
milliamp hours it might make the phone a
little bit heavier maybe it won't be the
thinnest thing in the world but I think
combining the Android L battery
improvements with the Nuart runtime with
a 15 to 20% larger battery could see
some serious improvement in all-day
battery use and that's really what we
all want isn't it now graphics now
whoever you use to make the new hardware
Google I'm sure the decisions already
been made but if you're watching this
don't skimp on the graphics please as
much as we love that the Nexus is a
notoriously inexpensive piece of
hardware as a phone we still love to see
a high-end graphics chip in there for
those of you who are at Google i/o or
we're watching the presentations about
Android L they made a big deal about how
all these new animations will run at a
smooth constant 60 frames per second
this is something project butter didn't
even do when it made a huge improvement
to graphics so that combined with a
high-end graphics chip to ensure that
there are no doubts could really make
this new Nexus the first Android phone
to compete with the silly buttery
smoothness of iOS so that's what I'm
really looking forward to seeing out of
the next Nexus whoever makes it whatever
size it is however big the bezels are or
whatever the deal is with it that is at
least what I would like to see now I
asked on Twitter what you guys wanted to
see and I got a lot of suggestions that
would be great but that I actually don't
expect to see first is expandable
storage with a micro SD card slot
nexuses and Google have consistently
moved away from that for the past couple
generations so I wouldn't expect to see
it same thing with a removable battery
even though that would be great to be
able to take it back off and just swap
out batteries they're implementing
wireless charging now and it's been
three generations of nexuses since we
had last had a removable battery so
again I wouldn't expect the next one to
suddenly take a backward step and lastly
there will never be another verizon
Nexus
I'm pretty confident about that and also
a 2.5 k display let 2560 by 1440 display
like we have in the Oppo find 7 and the
LG g3 again just probably to keep with
the trend of having a low cost phone and
that kind of stuff would also put a
strain on graphics so I would assume
we'd have to wait for the next next next
I guess the Nexus 7 net weight Nexus 4
Nexus 5 Nexus 6 Nexus 7 would they name
the next Nexus the Nexus 7 even though
we already have a tablet no probably not
speaking of tablets I just have to throw
this in there because it's been Oh a
year 8 months 20 days and thirteen and a
half hours since the last Nexus 10 was
released just saying it's been a while
there have been rumors of this HTC
volantis 9 inch all-metal front facing
speaker unibody new Nexus tablet coming
out but to be honest there is Nexus
rumors have been so few few and far
between it kind of sounds like fantasy
at this plane a lot of the rumors I keep
hearing for a new Nexus tablet sound
really unrealistic but when you think
about it the Nexus 10 at least at this
point is still a really solid tablet we
might not even need an upgrade I mean it
has a 2560 by 1440 big bright beautiful
display it has a 9000 milliamp hour
battery it's still thin it's still light
it still has those awesome front-facing
speakers
it's everything that it's set out to be
and I don't even know if we really need
an upgrade although it still would be
nice to have some refreshed hardware to
go with the new material design stuff so
what do you want to see in the next
Nexus is next next I Nexus at Nexus I
what do you what do you want to see in
the next Nexus phone and next Nexus
tablet feel free to comment below or
leave a thumbs up if you already agree
with what I gave in this wish list video
I definitely looking forward to see what
you guys post thank you for watching
this one another one coming up very soon
and I'll talk to you guys in the next
video peace